il ya quelqu'un
ouais
[Musique]
ok je crois en étant ce biais comment là
elle n'arrête pas de donner des coups de
pied et va bien une idée de comment on
va sortir d'ici je crois pas qu'on
devrait sortir ça ressemble pas vraiment
un pli on va geler là dedans mais tu
crois pas qu'on va geler l'adorent et la
lumière fut
j'ai juste besoin que tu me fasses
confiance d'accord démarre
mais c'est en bout la fsu je viens de
pisser sur une serviette il fait plus en
plus froid je sais qu est ce qu on voit
quand tu auras plus rien à manger on se
passe au rang des forces on doit casser
une fenêtre
c'est de la folie c'est de la folie
c'est ce n'était pas l'année dans la
nature sauvage et je les écoute
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui s'passe série qu'est ce
qui diffère torride en fait tu veux que
je lui tape dessus des swaps
terre
[Musique]